c'est souvent elizabeth qui pousse la
chansonnette au 9 rue de but qu elle vit
tout comme sept autres personnes en
colocation une coloc un peu particulière
tous sont atteints de la maladie
d'alzheimer
je pense que mes enfants mangent et un
châle tour je l'aurais mis à mener ici
parce que j'ai préféré être chez moi
honnêtement mais pour tout dire j'ai
petit à petit j'ai compris que dans
cette maison j'avais des relations des
matériels les affaires communes avec
d'autres personnes et que rester seul
dans mon appartement que ce n'était pas
une
bonne solution ma vie j'avais déjà mis à
proximité c'est que c'est un renouveau
de la personnalité je le sais d'autant
plus vous voulez que je crée mois des
résidences médicalisées
ici c'est pas une résidence médicalisée
c'est une résidence tout coup ces
personnes âgées profitent d'un concept
particulier nommé la maison des sages
est fondée par lisa l'immobilier
solidaire et associatif ouverte en mars
dernier aux loges en josas c'est la
deuxième maison du genre dans les
yvelines
on part du principe qu'une petite
communauté de vie dans une maison
ordinaire permet de déstigmatiser la
maladie et de ce centre est plutôt sur
la personne et de permettre plus tôt
quand n'est pas d'avoir un gros
collectif 200 personnes de 80 ou 100
personnes ou isolement et la sécurité du
domicile de trouver un bon compromis
entre la personne seule ou le
l'établissement en permettant
d'accompagner les personnes à leur
rythme 350 m² rénover un ascenseur créé
jardin cuisine ou encore salon salle à
manger sont partagés mais les chambres
elles sont complètement individualisé
pour un coût entre 2500 et 3500 euros
c'est vrai que colocation en france un
pas très bonne réputation et puis on
pense surtout aux étudiants qu'on est
comme chez soi avec un service
d'accompagnement qui sécurise qui
rassure à la fois les malades et les
aidants et qui permet aussi d'avoir des
activités comme une vie ordinaire une
vie ordinaire avec quelques règles
toutefois la journée est rythmée
toilettes soit un temps de pause entre
coupé de moments obligatoire les repas
en communauté
c'est pas parce qu'on est vieux qu'on
doit attendre de mourir en fait on a le
droit de vivre encore et de voilà de
danser de chanter de faire la cuisine
est en fait cette stimulation par
rapport à la maladie d'alzheimer
il a ses troubles de mémoire ils sont en
fait des personnes si elles sont dans un
cadre rassurant et protecteur
elles sont treize à l accueil beaucoup
la stimulation des activités sont aussi
proposés aux colocataires jeux de
société couture ou encore cuisine une
colocation somme toute classique
un peu comme en famille